[Musik]
mit ihrem Markenzeichen dem Pagenkopf
und dunkler Sonnenbrille beherrscht Anna
Winter das 300 Milliarden Dollar schwere
amerikanische mode-universum
ist der einflussreichste Mensch in der
Modewelt
wurde sie selbst zu einer Berühmtheit
mit dem Ruf einer guten Fee für manche
energy Anerkennung ist wichtig für alles
was ich tue und eines feuerspuck einem
Drachen für andere ich habe nahm gehört
wie Eiskönigin oder nuklearer Winter
aber um Ergebnisse zu erzielen musst du
anspruchsvoll sein ist sie ein warmer
sanfter Mensch nein warum sollte sie das
sein
ihr Einfluss ist über die Seiten des
hochglanzmagazins hinausgewachsen sie
ist einen Schrittmacher und drahtzia
sie ist die Frau die Mode international
und zum großen Geschäft gemacht hat
ich weiß nicht über Mode und ich lese
die Burg nicht regelmäßig aber ich weiß
eine Menge über Sie Anna Winter stellte
sich ohne Umschweife ihrem
sagenumwobenen Ruf bei einem ihrer
seltenen
fernsehauftrittes gelesen dass ich eine
Eiskönigin bin ich bin der Sonnenkönig
ich bin ein Alien aus dem District 9 und
eine Domina
also ich schätze das macht mich zu einer
lauwarmen Adeligen aus dem All mit einer
Peitsche
was denken Sie gute auftritt
[Applaus]
ist ihr Auftritt ist der der
Chefredakteurin der Burg 22 Jahre lang
hat die mächtige und einschüchternde
Bienenkönigin Frauen gesagt was und wen
sie zu tragen haben lange Röcke oder
kurze Royal oder marineblau oder das
Grau das neue Schwarz ist ich bete Mode
an ich bete an was sie über Frauen sagt
die Walk ist anerkannt wie kein anderes
Magazin und das ist unglaublich
befriedigend
anna ist revolutionär sie hat die ganze
modeindustrie-revolutioniert
[Musik]
anna ist jemand der mit Konkurrenzdenken
umgeht in einer Weise wie das jeder
machen sollte sie wird nicht wütend sie
wird ruhig
und lehnte es ab an unserem Programm
teilzunehmen
war schon als junge Frau ehrgeizig 1949
in London geboren verließ sie in den
60er Jahren die Schule und war
fasziniert von der Londoner
gesellschafts- und Kulturszene
ihre Mutter Elia nore Amerikanerin und
ihr britischer Vater Charles war der
abgebrühte Chefredakteur der Londoner
Zeitung the evening Standard Laurie
begann ihre Karriere als einer Winters
Assistentin
sie wuchs mit einem Journalisten auf
einem Zeitungsmann der herrschte ein
gewisser Standard eine strenge die sich
sicherlich auf sie ausgewirkt hat und so
geht sie nur noch alles an
als sie 20 waren bekam Günther ihren gut
bekleideten Fuß in die Tür beim gerade
gegründeten britischen Magazin Hape sind
Queen sie war außerordentlich eifrig sie
holte sich die besten Fotografen um die
Leiter hochzuklettern aber nach fünf
Jahren bei Harper sind Queen wurde sie
bei der Wahl eines neuen Chefredakteurs
übergangen
sie verließ das Magazin und England und
machte sich 1975 auf dem Weg zur seven
Avenue in New York
sitzt an der Spitze ihres eigenen
Mode-Unternehmens und Winter seit über
30 Jahren
sie war nicht an der Wintour die
Hohepriesterin der Vogue sie war meine
Freundin und wir waren zwei Mädchen die
versuchten etwas in der Modeindustrie in
Gang zu bringen
anna war definitiv darauf aus in
Zeitschriftengeschäft zu gehen und vor
allem zur Vogue
musste noch warten ihren ersten Job in
New York hatte Winter bei Harper und
wurde gefeuert weil sie wie sie in einem
Zeitungsinterview sagte zu europäisch
war
nach ein paar Monaten ohne Arbeit nahm
sie einen Jobangebot vom Herausgeber des
penthouse-magazins Bob guccioni an als
mode-redakteurin bei Viva einem
erotik-magazin für Frauen ihre Model
Layouts gewannen an Anerkennung ein paar
Jahre später bekam sie ihren ersten
großen Job
mode-redakteurin beim New York Magazine
sie war ein totales Rätsel ein
faszinierendes Rätsel sie trug diese
dunkle Sonnenbrille so ziemlich die
ganze Zeit es hieß schwimmen oder sinke
sie sagte was sie wollte aber nicht wie
du es machen sollst ich habe in zwei
Wochen vier Kilo verloren weil das die
ganze Zeit so ging
Winter erarbeitete sich einen Ruf für
stilvolle Layouts und eine unerbittliche
Arbeitsmoral
[Musik]
sie hatte eine sehr festgelegte
Tagesordnung sie hatte den Mut und den
Schneid und die Intelligenz und die
Energie um all das zu tun
es hat nicht lange gedauert bis die
Manager bei condy Nast sein new house
und Alexander Liebermann auf sie
aufmerksam wurden Tom florian war
Verlagsleiter bei der Vogue und kennt
Winter seit 30 Jahren
dieser Anfangszeit fühlte sich fast an
wie in einem jungen Hollywoodstudio und
Herren und Alex hatten einfach diesen
großartigen Sinn nicht nur dafür wie man
ein Magazin hochzieht sondern auch für
die Persönlichkeiten die diese Magazine
leiten sollten die Organisation hat
Leute mit einer Vision und mit
Entschlossenheit und Tatkraft wirklich
mit offenen Armen begrüßt niemand hatte
mehr Tatkraft als einer Winter sie wurde
mit einem Job bei der Vogel belohnt denn
nur für Sie geschaffen wurde es war
nicht der Job den sie sich gewünscht
hatte den hatte bereits die langjährige
Chefredakteurin
es gab offensichtlich Widerstand aber
wenn Anna hereinkommt ist sie kann
Mauerblümchen und macht Ihren Standpunkt
klar und deshalb wurde sie dorthin
geholt
Winter Standpunkt kam bei Mirabella
nicht gut an in ihrer Autobiografie
bezeichnete sie die neue
Kreativdirektorin als kalte und
misstrauische Person die immer gegen sie
arbeitete um ihre Autorität zu
untergraben sie schrieb dass sie das
Gefühl habe dass Winter darauf
vorbereitet wurde ihren Job zu
übernehmen
ich glaube es gab welche die sich
bedroht fühlten sie kannten sie nicht
sie wussten nicht genau warum sie hier
war und sie würden nicht jeden neuen
einfach so willkommen heißen
wir mal gerne ganz zu schweigen von
jemandem wie Anna die eine ziemlich gute
Figur machte und definitiv die
Aufmerksamkeit der großen
Entscheidungsträger von Conny Nest auf
sich zog
[Musik]
nach einem dreijährigen Machtkampf legte
condy Nast einen Ozean zwischen sie
wohnten Winter eine Beförderung zu
Chefredakteurin der britischen Burg an
ein weiterer Schritt auf der
Karriereleiter der mit hohen
persönlichen Kosten verbunden war
Winter zog mit ihrem Baby nach London
während ihr Mann in New York
1986 kam sie nach London und begann
sofort dass Erscheinungsbild der
britischen Burg zu verändern
im gewisser Weise machte sie sie
bodenständiger für Leute die auf der
Suche nach Dingen waren die Sie auch
kaufen konnten und sie machte das
Magazin nutzerfreundlicher den Lesern
mag diese Abwechslung gefallen haben
aber ihre Mitarbeiter waren nicht so
begeistert sie gaben ihr einen
Spitznamen der blieb nuklearer
Wintergarten wenn man nicht viel sagt
und die Leute nicht einbindet aber das
führt dazu dass sich der Rest der Welt
selbst überlegt was wohl Sache ist Zink
ist
sie warm und sanft nein warum sollte sie
ist sie jemand dessen Meinung man gerne
hätte absolut nach 18 Monaten holte
condynast den aufstrebenden Star zurück
nach New York um ihr einrichtungsmagazin
Haus im Garten zu überholen
Winter änderte den Titel in age g
tauschte Bilder von leeren Räumen gegen
üppige Fotostrecken von Promis in ihren
Häusern
manche Leser empörten sich und die
Zeitschrift war gezwungen Abos
war damals dienstälteste
mode-redakteurin beim Wall Street
Journal und Autorin des Buches das Ende
der Mode
deshalb nenne ich Anna revolutionär weil
sie in so ein etabliertes Magazin
einsteigt und so etwas radikales tut
die Gefahr dass man scheitert ist so
hoch wenn man etwas so mutiges macht
andere Karrieren wären von solchen
Misserfolgen beendet wurden doch nicht
die Anna Winters hatte noch andere Pläne
mit ihr es war das am schlechtesten
gehütete Geheimnisse der Modewelt es gab
Gerüchte dass wintor Chefredakteurin der
amerikanischen Vogue werden und die
Veteranen Grace Mirabelle ersetzen würde
nun die heiße Story ist dass das wohl
auch passieren wird nach 17 Jahren war
Mirabella raus die 38-Jährige einer
Winter bekam den Job den sie immer
wollte ihre Vision war von ihrem ersten
Cover an klar sie kombinierte ein 10.000
$ Oberteil mit einer 40 Dollar Jeans
das war etwas neues revolutionäres das
war eine neue Herausgeberin sie war
Britin sie war stilvoll sie war jung und
sie hatte einen Standpunkt wir wussten
dass das eine neue Ära sein würde
in einem Interview im Dezember 88
erklärte Winter was es heißt
Chefredakteurin der Wok zu sein ich
denke das Wichtigste in diesem Job ist
den richtigen Instinkt und das richtige
Bauchgefühl zu haben um ein Magazin zu
produzieren das aus dem Moment heraus
geboren wird das einfach einfängt was
jetzt gerade passiert
man muss mittendrin sein
[Musik]
mirabellas traditionelle Titelbilder
wurden durch Winters frischen neuen Look
ersetzt
sie scheute keine Kosten für aufwendige
Shootings mit den besten Fotografen
[Musik]
wusste genau wie Sie unseren Wunsch nach
Flucht und Schönheit und echter Mode
verbindet und mit dem Bedürfnis nach den
Dingen die uns Frauen wichtig sind Dinge
die zu unserem Lebensstil passen wer wir
sind und wo wir herkommen
wieder einmal erkannte Winter die
Anziehungskraft von Promis und er setzte
Supermodels durch Superstars auf den
Cover
Filmemacher
hat sehr früh erkannt dass die Macht der
Prominenten die globale Industrie und
die Mode zusammen kamen
wir hatten die mega-marken Gucci Prada
age berufstätige Frauen übernahmt
Führungspositionen also brauchten sie
powerkleidung für die Arbeit
den Wunsch die Menschen träumen nach
etwas Streben zu lassen sie zu
inspirieren
aber sie verstand auch wie sich die Mode
als Geschäft verändert hatte
[Musik]
Winters steigendes ansehen führte zu
steigenden Werbeeinnahmen
Square daily das Werbegeschäft kann sehr
launisch sein sie müssen im Laufe der
Zeit Loyalität aufbauen sie müssen den
Werbetreibenden einen echten Mehrwert
und Gründe bieten um konsequent in ihren
Publikationen zu bleiben weil es eine
der wettbewerbsfähigsten Branchen der
Welt ist
innerhalb von zehn Jahren stiegen die
Werbeeinnahmen von knapp über 87
Millionen Dollar auf fast 150 Millionen
Dollar der Erfolg der Vogue brachte
Winter wachsenden Einfluss
ihre Auftritte in den ersten Reihen der
Modeschauen mit ihrer dunklen
Sonnenbrille erhielten eine ganz neue
Bedeutung jeder eisige Gesichtsausdruck
wurde nach Hinweisen durchsucht
[Musik]
anna wurde ein wichtiger showgast wenn
sie da war war es wie eine Bestätigung
dass deine Show cool ist eine große
Sache
unter Winter verwandelte sich die Vogue
vom Magazin zur Marke
der Erfolg rückte auch Sie in den
öffentlichen Fokus
1999 berichteten die Boulevardzeitungen
über ihre Scheidung und ihre Beziehung
zum texanischen Telekom Millionär Shelly
Brian showby
die Leute tratschten und spekulierten
über jede ihrer Bewegungen aber sie hat
es im Grunde genommen ignoriert und ich
glaube das war klug
ungestört richtete Winter ihre
Aufmerksamkeit auf das was der Wurf
bevorstand ihre Antwort war ausnahmslos
dieselbe die Leute fragen immer war das
ihre lieblingskollektion war das ihre
lieblingsausgabe aber für mich ist es
immer die nächste das was kommt es ist
immer die Zukunft die meisten Redakteure
denken nicht über ihren Titel hinaus
aber Anna denkt über die Welt nach und
wie sie den Titel beeinflusst und auch
darüber wie der Titel die Welt
beeinflussen kann
früherer Präsident des Kontinent
sie kennt alle Aspekte des Marketings
sei es die Vermarktung der Marke für den
Verbraucher oder für die Werbepartner
sozialen Einfluss sie positioniert die
Marke mit Blick auf all diese Parameter
um die Marke zu erweitern brachte sie
2003 die teamvogue heraus gefolgt von
der manswalk und der vogliving
innerhalb eines Jahres sanken jedoch die
Werbeeinnahmen für die mens-
[Musik]
Erweiterung hatte am Ende nicht
funktioniert sie war aber trotzdem ein
produktives Experiment sie geht Risiken
ein sie arbeitet wirklich sehr hart und
wenn es nicht funktioniert dann schiebt
sie es beiseite erholt sich und versucht
einfach aus der Sache zu lernen und
weiter zu machen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
Winters erhöhte Sichtbarkeit und ihre
öffentliche Unterstützung der
Pelzindustrie führten zu wilden
Konfrontationen
auf dem Höhepunkt der anti-pelzbewegung
war Anna sehr bestimmt sie trug ihre
Pelze die Demonstranten tauchten bei den
Shows auf
sie aßens und jemand legte ihr ein totes
Tier auf den
telleries läufst und jemand dich mit
Pastete bewirft und dich niederschlägt
ist das ziemlich aggressiv aber sie
stand auf wischte sich das Gesicht ab
ging zurück ins Hotel zog sich um und
ging zum nächsten Treffen
danach bekam sie Personenschutz wenn Sie
eine Show besuchte hatte sie diese
beiden Bodyguards dabei
diesen Mythos zu schwören dass sie eine
Klasse für sich ist
sie steckte in ihrem stylischen
Stilettos und ließ sich in ihre
Unterstützung für die milliardenschwere
Pelzindustrie nicht beirren die
berühmter sie wurde desto mehr negative
Aufmerksamkeit bekam sie der Roman der
Teufel trägt Prada wurde von vielen in
der Modebranche als schlecht getarnte
und vernichtende Darstellung von Winter
angesehen
die Hollywood-Version mit Meryl Streep
war ein riesen Erfolg und spielte
weltweit über 326 Millionen Dollar in
den Kinos ein
[Musik]
dieser Ruf des Drachens wird auf
porträtiert ich glaube es gibt ja eine
Agenda Problem weil sie eine Frau ist
erwarten die Leute dass sie sich auf
eine bestimmte Art und Weise verhält
wenn Sie eine Firma leiten würde wäre
das überhaupt kein Thema
Winter war inzwischen eine anerkannte
Grüße mit weitreichenden Beziehungen in
der gesamten Modebranche
sie hat auch anderen sehr großen Marken
geholfen
wenn die nach einem Designer oder einem
Kreativdirektor suchten hat sie auch
diesen Marken zum Erfolg verholfen
[Musik]
eine Marke die ihre Hilfe brauchte war
gern seit Jahren wird das Unternehmen
unter sinkenden Umsätzen sie
konsultierten Günther und sie empfahl
den jungen Designer Patrick romance
sie hat mich angerufen und ich hatte
auch schon drüber nachgedacht und sie
erklärte mir wie dieser Job aussehen
könnte also wie Sie sich das vorstellen
würde
sie war ein großartiger Resonanzboden
als sich über den Job nachgedacht habe
ihre Vermittlung funktioniert das 2007
wurde
robinsoner
ist es immer noch sie sieht bis heute
alles was ich tue
aber nach vier Jahren glanzloser
Ergebnisse entließ gab seinen
Stardesigner winter's Interesse an der
Förderung neuer Talente ließ aber nicht
nach und sie gründete den Vogue
fashion-pfand für Stipendien und
Unternehmensberatung
man muss für Nachwuchs sorgen das war
Anna sehr wichtig
das ist mehr Designer gibt also auch
mehr Werbung und mehr Umsatz das ist
alles ein Kreislauf
und so kam es 2007
mit der September Ausgabe der Wohnung
das Magazin hatte rekordverdächtige 727
Seiten mit Werbeanzeigen
die erfolgsdokumentation die
September-Ausgabe gewährt einen seltenen
Einblick in die Modewelt mit der
anspruchsvollen Frau im Dauerlauf es ist
wunderschön danach bin ich nicht so
verrückt
die sieht schwanger aus nein dieser
Schnitt wirkt so groß
sieht aus wie für eine blinde
[Musik]
schaut nicht zurück sie schaut nach
vorne sie verzweifelt nicht sie vertraut
sich selbst sie braucht eine dicke Haut
aber auch unter einer dicken Haut sind
Nerven Nerven aus Stahl brauchte sie
mit wirtschaftlichen Umständen
konfrontiert die wir nie für möglich
gehalten hätten
[Musik]
2009 zwang die tiefste Rezession seit
Jahrzehnten die Unternehmen dazu
Werbegelder zu kürzen
die anzeigenverkäufe der Vogue für die
wichtige Septemberausgabe brachen ein
von 727 auf 429
seitens Unternehmen das keine
Finanzergebnisse veröffentlicht
aber ganz offensichtlich stand das
Unternehmen unter Druck sechs
Zeitschriften wurden eingestellt und
hunderte von Stellen gestrichen das
kronjuwelbuchstützungen
als aber auch im Modeviertel von
Manhattan der Umsatz einbrach
tratwinter in Aktion
ihre Idee war ein weltweites
verkaufssevent
die fashions night auf
danke dass Sie heute Abend gekommen seid
der Töne
das war ein beispielloses Ereignis das
über 1.000 Einzelhändler auf der ganzen
Welt zusammenbrachte tausende und
abertausende von Verbrauchern
überfluteten die Geschäfte
das Event war so erfolgreich dass es zu
einer jährlichen Veranstaltung wurde wir
möchten uns bei euch allen für euer
Kommen bedanken wie geht es Euch heute
Abend
Winter sprang auch ein um einen der
Schätze New Yorks zu retten die
kostümsammlung im Metropolitan Museum of
Art als Kopf einer Spendenaktion
moderierte sie die jährliche Benefizgala
das war etwas das sogar mit den Oscars
konkurrierte
Emily Rafferty damals Präsidentin des
Metropolitan Museum of Art in dem Jahr
haben wir durch ihre Führung in einer
Nacht über neun Millionen Dollar
gesammelt mitten in einer Rezession und
es lagen noch weitere gewaltige
Herausforderungen vor Winter hatte sich
nur langsam an das digitale Zeitalter
angepasst jetzt hingen Winters Zukunft
und die der Vogue davon ab
jeden Monat Zeitschrift muss wirklich
prüfen ob Bedarf an schnellen
Informationen besteht und wie decken Sie
diese Nachfrage
ihr monatlich erscheinen des Magazin
sieht sich zunehmender Konkurrenz
ausgesetzt das gab Design an eine neue
Plattform um ihre Entwürfe direkt zu
präsentieren und gleichzeitig ihre
Produkte zu verkaufen ohne sich auf
Hochglanz Fotostrecken in der Burg zu
verlassen
ich garantiere Ihnen das Anna das Spiel
der digitalen Inhalte verändern wird
wir bringen markeninhalte mit ihrer
Stimme zu Millionen von Verbrauchern die
wir mit einem Magazin als einzigen
Medium unmöglich erreichen könnten
[Musik]
ihre Kritiker glauben dass sie über den
Medien steht sie ist die Kuratorin der
Mode weltweit fashion
[Musik]
macht fast jeden Tag etwas das ist enorm
sie hat immer Ideen wie man diese
Branche voranbringen Sie immer weiter
vorantreiben kann
diese Industrie ist mehrere hundert
Milliarden Dollar schwer und das ist
vielleicht nur ein Nebenprodukt von
vielen aber eines davon ist einerseitung
des vogue-magazins für mehr als 20 Jahre
dieses unglaubliche Gefühl dafür was
gute Mode ist was Talent und Kreativität
sind
sie ist nicht hier nur um zu sagen ob
ein Kleid schön ist oder nicht oder ob
ein neuer Schuh growig genug ist sie ist
da um die gesamte Branche zu ermutigen
Nachwuchstalente etablierte Talente für
alle ist es schwer im Rennen zu bleiben
aber sie sieht das als ihre Pflicht an
das ist auch ihr Vermächtnis sie ist die
Frau die Mode wirklich in das Big
Business und in die Welt gebracht hat
[Musik]
[Applaus]
er ist die regierende Supermacht der
Modewelt in unserer Branche sieht jeder
Rave Lauren als Vorbild an ein
traumfabrikant der Milliarden verdiente
indem er sich vorstellte was andere sich
wünschten jedes Mal wenn ich Kleidung
entwerfe mache ich einen Film ich glaube
seit Walt Disney war niemand so
erfolgreich darin Millionen und aber
Millionen von Menschen für seine
Fantasien zu begeistern
strahlt eine Aura des gehobenen
Lebenshaus als Marke steht für
klassische zeitlos
die Marke ist ihre Erinnerung an diesen
fabelhaften Lebensstil aber sein Leben
war nicht so perfekt ich glaube er
dachte das wäre das letzte Mal dass er
den falschen Weg eingeschlagen hat das
war es aber nicht bei weitem nicht wir
haben immer geschert dass er immer den
Plan hatte die Welt zu übernehmen er hat
die Welt übernommen daran besteht kein
Zweifel
[Musik]
Ralph Lauren ist die berühmteste
einmannmarke des Planeten eine Marke die
Synonym für einen überlegenen Lebensstil
ist Ralf wusste immer dass er nicht
gewinnen würde wenn er keine Risiken
eingeht und er geht immer an die Grenzen
er hält sich nachts wach er hat Angst er
könnte Versagen er ist besessen brillant
unberechenbar und schwierig aber er kann
auch nett und interessant und süß sein
er ist ein Bündel von widersprechen
Lauren besteht darauf dass die Bilder
von ihm seine Geschichte erzählen und
wollte nicht an unserem Programm
teilnehmen bevor er Ralph Lauren war war
er ralfshit das jüngste von vier Kindern
dass die Kleider des Bruders auftrug
1939 als Sohn jüdische Einwanderer aus
der Arbeiterklasse geboren wuchs er in
der Bronze New York auf sein Vater war
Amateurkünstler wenn man mit jemandem
zusammen lebt für den Ästhetik wichtig
ist hat das Auswirkungen auf das Kind in
diesem Haushalt
Michael Gross
das wirkliche Leben von Ralph lawn er
ging zur yoshiba und trug eine Kippa und
alle anderen Utensilien orthodoxer Juden
jeden Tag
erzählte mir dass er ganz am Anfang als
er in der Bronx lebte ins Kino ging und
sich buchstäblich in die Fantasien der
Filme dieser Ära stürzte die wirklich
eine der großen kino-epochen der späten
40er und frühen 50er Jahre war
einer der Jugendfreunde von Lauren wir
alle haben als Kinder auf die
Kinoleinwände geguckt und auf die
Schauspieler und wie gut sie aussahen
Ralf mochte vor allem Fred als there
und er hat sich wirklich in die Szenen
hineinversetzt in denen Männer wie Gary
Cooper und Cary Grant spielten
er sieht die Figuren die seine Träume
und seine Visionen bevölkern und diese
Vision diese Fähigkeit in eine
Fantasiewelt einzutauchen hat Wolf in
die Modebranche mitgebracht
in einem der beiden einzigen großen
Fernsehinterview wünschte er je gegeben
hat erzählte Lauren 1993 Charlie Rose
von den Auswirkungen dieser Erfahrungen
ich wurde sehr von Filmen beeinflusst
von einer Welt die einen Sinn für Träume
hatte einen Sinn für etwas anderes
ich war sehr
starker einen Schneider als Teenager
darum bat ihm einen seiner ersten Anzüge
zu machen ich erinnere mich dass ich mit
ihm zu meinem Vater ging und es ist sehr
schwierig war ich sagte zu meinem Vater
Papa mach was er will er sagte ich kann
es ihm nicht recht machen
sagte okay das war's auch wenn er einen
Perfektionist war Lauren war ein Mann
für alle Fälle er mochte Basketball am
liebsten würde ich sagen okay alles gut
wie geht es ihnen free ihn auf seiner
Ranch in Colorado interviewte erzählte
Lauren von seinen frühesten Ambitionen
wollten Sie schon immer ein Cowboy sein
wollte Baseballspieler werden wollte
Schauspieler werden wollte Tänzer werden
eigentlich wollte die Batman werden dass
das Geheimnis dass ich ihn verrate und
einmal draußen
als Teenager entschieden er und sein
Bruder Jerry sich für einen
Namensänderung Ralf sagte zu mir das
Problem mit dem Namen Lipschitz ist dass
er das Wort enthält und er musste
endlose Hänseleien über sich ergehen
lassen die sich durch die ganze
Schulzeit zogen und auch in der Armee
Ralf schlug mir vor dass der Name Lauren
von Lauren becall kommt die eine große
Stilikone und Schauspielerin war
nach der Highschool arbeitete als
Verkäufer abends versuchte er
wirtschaftskurse einen Abschluss hat er
nie gemacht 1964 nach einem kurzen
Abstecher in die Armee heiratete der
26-Jährige Lauren Rice einer
Empfangsdame die er in einer Arztpraxis
kennengelernt hatte er heiratete das
Mädchen das in Cabrio perfekt aussah mit
ihrem blonden Haaren Ricky wurde sein
Model seinen Rückhalt Ricky war glaube
ich immer in seinem Hinterkopf
[Musik]
immer noch auf der Suche nach seinem
Platz in der Welt wandte sich Lauren der
New Yorker Modebranche zu er wurde
Verkäufer bei Brooks Brothers und dann
bei einer Reihe von krawattenherstellern
ich nahm ihn zu seinem ersten Polospiel
in blindbrook mit wo wir all diese
fabelhaften Dinge sagen
die großen schlanken Blondinen die
großen Hüter
wir nichts wussten
rief mich an und sagte er wolle sich
selbstständig machen und was ich von dem
Namen halten würde der sagte er denkt an
players
kaum jemand weiß etwas darüber aber
jeder spielt etwas also hast du keine
Wahl es muss players sein er sagte okay
vielen Dank auf Wiedersehen
und der Rest ist Geschichte
es waren die Ära der einfarbigen
schmalen Krawatten als Lauren etwas
radikales vorschlug bunte breite
Krawatten
er machte sich selbstständig eine seiner
ersten Stationen blumingdales Marvin
Trump war damals CEO und Präsident von
bloomingance kurz vor seinem Tod sprach
er über den forschen jungen Designer
er zeigte sie dem krawatteneinkäufer von
Bloomingdales der sagte die gefallen mir
die Taufe
aber ich will nicht dass Ralph Lauren
Label drauf haben ich will ein Blumen
dayleben
er machte den Koffer zu und sagte ohne
meinen Namen will ich den Auftrag nicht
[Musik]
einige Monate nachdem Ralph Lauren das
Angebot von blooming Dates ausgeschlagen
hatte rief ihn das renommierte
Unternehmen zurück ich fand die
Krawatten großartig und wenn er seinen
Namen drauf haben wollte war das okay
ich war sicher dass ich die Krawatten
verkaufen würden und das taten sie auch
andere bekannte Namen in der
herrenbekleidungsbranche wollten auch
mitmachen
und nehmen Markus innerhalb eines Jahres
verkaufte Lauren Krawatten für eine
halbe Million Dollar
und er hatte noch größeres vor
seiner Marke zu erweitern er wollte das
tun indem er sich Kleidung vorstellte
die er selbst tragen würde
du dachtest du kannst in England kaufen
was Cary Grant es fred ist der trug aber
du konntest nicht in ein Geschäft gehen
und es kaufen als ich kam war das
Geschäft überhaupt nicht so die Sachen
die ich machte könnte man nicht kaufen
man konnte sie nicht finden blooming
Dates sah das Potenzial und den Profit
in Lorenz Linie
von Krawatten über Herrenhemden bis hin
zu Anzügen Sportjacken Rosen die ganze
Kollektion und dann kam mir und sagte
Marvin ich will eine Damenkollektion
machen
der wichtigste Durchbruch für Ralph
Lauren war wahrscheinlich dass er eine
eigene Boutique bei blooming days bekam
das war der Moment wo jemand außerhalb
seiner Fantasiewelt ihm zustimmte und
ihn in die Geschäftswelt einführte
es war das erste Mal das Bloomingdales
einem Designer eine eigene bout ihren
Geschäft gab
und das Geschäft wuch sehr schnell Ralf
wusste genau was er im Laden wollte was
er auf den Etagen wollte und was er an
den Wänden wollte
es entstand ein richtiges Ralph lawren
Umfeld
das war Ralphs
wenn man sich die 60er und 70er Jahre
ansieht da wurde Kleidung auf
Schaufensterpuppen gepackt sie haben die
Geschichten erzählt Ralph nahm dich in
eine Fantasiewelt mit auf eine Insel in
die Hamptons in den Wilden Westen
drei Jahre nach dem Verkauf seiner
ersten Krawatten gewann Lauren 1970 den
Oscar der Modebranche den Cody Award für
seine mansware-linie und 1971 kaufte
Lauren das erste von vielen Luxusautos
der Pulitzerpreis Architektur und
Designkritiker Paul Goldberger hat über
Rolf Lawrence berühmte autosammlung
berichtet ich glaube es war ein Mercedes
Cabrio dass er sich zu diesem Zeitpunkt
nicht ganz leisten konnte er kaufte es
trotzdem weil er genau diese Art von
Aufstreben verstand die er anderen
Leuten zu verkaufen versuchte
auch seine frühere Fantasie zurück das
Polo Spiel und führte sein Logo ein den
Polospieler aber trotz des starken
Umsatzes Gerät das Unternehmen in
finanzielle Schwierigkeiten
Lauren war gezwungen den größten Teil
seiner persönlichen Ersparnisse zu
investieren 100.000 Dollar er stellte
auch einen neuen Geschäftspartner ein
den einzelhandelsmanager Peter strong
der einsprang und 10% des Unternehmens
für 6000 Dollar kaufte ich glaube er war
sehr besorgt sie lieferten alles zu spät
ihr vertriebsmuster war völlig falsch
wir lösten diese Probleme und brachten
die richtigen Läden dazu die richtige
Menge zu kaufen und alles richtig zu
präsentieren
zwei Jahre später wieder auf dem
richtigen Weg bekam Lorenz Marke einen
Aufschwung als seine Männerkleidung im
großen Gatsby mitspielte seine Fähigkeit
Kleider zu entwerfen die wie Kostüme
aussahen die wie Kleider aussahen die
wie Kostüme aussahen war unvergleichlich
glaube dass der Claim den er entwarf
Annie Hall wichtiger war der Annie
hall-look inspirierte eine der ersten
Damenkollektionen von Ralph Lauren und
der Designer selbst war auf das
hauptmodel in den Werbekampagnen seiner
Marke
verkaufschef Jeff Madoff hat auf vielen
seiner Modenschauen fotografiert
er trägt diese Sachen also ist der zur
Verkörperung dessen geworden was er
kreiert
mit seinen Hühnern wissen Sie Ralf in
seinen Kleidern das war authentisch
das Unternehmen brachte eine Reihe neuer
Kollektionen heraus darunter auch eine
umfangreiche haushaltskollektion Lauren
lizenzierte seinen Namen auch für andere
Produkte und tauschte damit Kontrolle
gegen Kapital ein
1986 ging Ralph Lauren aufs Ganze und
gab 30 Millionen Dollar aus um einen
eigenständigen Flagship Store zu
eröffnen
in der historischen Rheinländer Menschen
in New York City
meine Frau und ich waren dort am
Eröffnungstag um 14 Uhr und der Laden
war voll und ich sagte Ralf wie geht es
Dir
ich glaube es geht mir gut ich sagte du
bist Einzelhändler du kannst jetzt die
Kasse klingeln lassen und der Manager
sagte wir haben 4 20.000 eingenommen
Ralf fragte ist das gut und ich sagte
das ist sehr gut dann ging ich zurück in
mein Büro und das Telefon klingelte
gegen halb sechs und es war Ralf Marvin
wir haben hunderttausend Dollar wie ist
das und ich sagte es ist großartig
er lernte Einzelhändler zu
seiner Geschichte erzählt jeder der nach
New York kommt es ist ja sogar im
turguide von New York man versteht Ralph
Lawrence botschafte man dort durchgeht
schon wenn man an diesen Fenstern
vorbeikommt als das Unternehmen weiter
wuchs setzte Lauren seiner Mitarbeiter
mehr denn je unter Druck
es gibt ein riesiges Team von Designern
und kreativen Führungskräften sie
entwerfen machen alles aber bringen es
zu rauf und Ralf ist es der entscheidet
es gibt da diese erstaunlichen Teile
kleine Aufkleber die auf Ideen Tafeln
angebracht werden da steht drauf
und mit diesem Akten im Ralph Lauren die
Kleider die Designs in Besitz und
verdient die Anerkennung
mehr auf die Details als jeder andere
den ich in meinem Leben getroffen habe
und wenn er entwirft und sich die
Kleider ansieht
schau da hin und will ein Revers das
noch viel spitzer ist auch viel schmaler
sein soll
1986 hatte das Unternehmen einen
geschätzten Wert von 600 Millionen
Dollar und Lauren selbst war das
Titelbild nicht seine Modelle es schien
als könnte das Leben für ihn nicht
besser werden als er seine nächste
Damenkollektion herausbrachte aber
hinter den Kulissen wurde der Designer
von etwas alarmierendem erschüttert
wir waren oben im Sand reach
Ralf kam raus und ich sah sein Gesicht
wie ich noch nie gesehen hatte
ich mit den tränenkämpfter ich fing an
zu weinen irgendetwas ging da vor sich
die wusste nicht mal was es war einfach
intuitiv
nur die Menschen die ihm am nächsten
standen wussten dass bei Lauren ein
Hirntumor festgestellt worden war
es war eines dieser Dinge die man
einfach nicht glauben konnte die Ralf
nicht passieren konnten was bedeutet das
für die Zukunft es gab damals so viele
Fragen
[Musik]
als ich im Taxi nach Hause fuhren in den
Nachrichten hörte dass der Designer
Ralph Lauren für eine Gehirnoperation
eingeliefert wurde
wow oh ja mein Gott
natürlich habe ich mir Sorgen gemacht ja
tat mir so leid wissen Sie
zum Glück war der Tumor gutartig nach
der Operation lag ein langer Weg vor ihm
und neue Prioritäten ich glaube nicht
dass er sich Sorgen darüber gemacht hat
was mit dem Geschäft passiert er hat
sich Sorgen um das Leben gemacht Lauren
teilte sein matteoum mit Charlie Rose
ich weiß noch als ich aus dem
Krankenhaus kam und im Central Park
spazieren ging
ich war sehr schwach er sah ich ein paar
Jungs den Park rannten und schwitzten
und ich sagte zu mir das will ich auch
machen
einige Wochen später kehrte Lauren zur
Arbeit zurück ich glaube er kam sogar
aggressiver zurück als je zuvor aber ich
glaube er war ein bisschen entspannter
ein bisschen gelassener und schätzte
vielleicht jeden Moment ein bisschen
mehr
er brachte eine Kollektion für
Fitnesskleidung heraus und entwarf ein
Umsatz starkes Parfum er gab Millionen
aus um diese Produktlinien zu fördern
James
bezeichnet Ralph Lauren als ein
Kraftpaket in der magazinwelt weil er
einer der größten Werbekunden ist wenn
ich mein Parfüm auf dem Markt bringe und
eine Anzeigenserie schalte machen Sie
ein Profil von mir gucken Sie sich mal
die Anzahl der Magazine an die ihnen auf
das Cover gesetzt haben kurze sein
40-jähriges Jubiläum hatte das spiegelt
das Ausmaß wieder indem sie seine
finanzielle Unterstützung der letzten
Jahren zu schätzen wussten
zu schätzen wussten und auch darauf
angewiesen waren ein jährlicher
Werbeetat von 200 Millionen Dollar ist
ein 800 Pfund schwerer Gorilla Ralph
Lauren sitzt wo immer er will und wenn
das das Cover ihres Magazins ist dann
wird Ralf dort sein
Lawrence Dominanz wurde auch deutlich
als Audrey Hepburn ihm den Preis des
amerikanischen Modedesigner Rats für
sein Lebenswerk überreichte das war eine
seiner Musen seiner Ikone Audrey Hepburn
die Frau die als kleines Kind in den
Filmen gesehen hat
überreicht ihm jetzt diese Statue für
ihn der Oskar hätte sein können
erinnern Sie sich an die Prinzessin ich
habe sie
mit der Einführung von Lawrence lila
Label 1994 sah das Unternehmen für das
ungeübte Auge großartig aus schließlich
waren die Umsätze so hoch wie nie aber
das war nur die halbe Geschichte dieser
probaka ist
einzelhandelsjournalistin
wie jeder einzelne Händler der große
Träume hat Wuchs ist einfach zu schnell
es wurde viel Kapital aufgewendet um die
Marke dorthin zu bringen wo er sie haben
wollte das in Verbindung mit einem sehr
glanzlosen Vertrieb schuf den perfekten
Sturm für ein Unternehmen das fast am
Rande des Bankrott stand
Lauren brauchte einen Rettungsanker und
fand ihn bei Goldman Sex die
Investmentfirma kaufte 28% von Polo
Ralph Lauren für 135 Millionen Dollar
das war für uns überraschend weil wir
nicht wussten dass er finanziell so weit
mit dem Rücken zur Wand stand und ich
glaube das hat zu der Goldman Sachs
Investition geführt
sie sind sehr gut darin herauszufinden
welche Unternehmen langfristiges
Wachstum versprechen und genau das haben
sie bei Ralph Lauren gesehen die
Finanzspritze führte zu einem
exponentiellen Wachstum und Polo Ralph
Lauren eröffnete neue Läden und
renovierte ältere
1997 war Ralph Lauren der meistverkaufte
Designer der Welt die Verbraucher gaben
fast 5 Milliarden Dollar pro Jahr für
seine Produkte aus Goldman Sachs sah
noch größeres Potenzial und drängte ihn
zum Börsengang doch er war nicht so
sicher
er hatte immer bedenken dass er in einer
Aktiengesellschaft weniger
ausbildungsfreiheit haben würde das ist
nicht mehr seine eigene Marke war weil
er mit Aktionären und einem Vorstand zu
tun hatte
[Musik]
trotz seiner anfänglichen Vorbehalte
beschloss Ralph lawren im Juni 97 sein
Unternehmen an die Börse zu bringen Liss
dann
einzelhandels-gang besteht darin dass
die Investoren von Quartal zu Quartal
von Jahr zu Jahr ein sehr gleichmäßiges
Wachstum sehen wollen und ich glaube
dass sie in den ersten Tagen als
Aktiengesellschaft damit zu kämpfen
hatten nach dem Börsengang berichteten
wir über seine Jahresversammlung in der
stand vor den Aktionären und sagte die
Wall Street versteht mich nicht unsere
Anteilseigner sitzen nur da ich wünschte
sie würden verstehen was wir tun
Lauren versuchte nun die Aktionäre
zufriedenzustellen wer verkaufte in mehr
Läden aber das Umsatzwachstum
verlangsamtte sich und die Gewinnmargen
gingen zurück 16 Monate nach dem
Höchststand von 33 Dollar pro Aktie fiel
sie unter 17 Dollar I know ich weiß dass
es ihn gequält hat wir haben darüber
gesprochen er war frustriert dass die
Wall Street nicht das sehen konnte was
ihm völlig klar war und seit 1967 immer
klar gewesen war dass er es war dass er
der Mann war es trieb ihn in den
Wahnsinn und in dieses Umfeld kam ein
Mann namens Roger Ferrer der einer der
großen einzelhandelsmanager Amerikas war
Roger Feder kam und Reh strukturierte
die uns sexy Teile des Geschäfts
Lieferkette Betrieb und was er auch tat
er kaufte die Lizenzen zurück er brachte
diese Marke zurück ins Haus und stellte
sicher dass all diese Marken unter dem
Dach von Ralph Lauren waren
sie machten gerade eine enorme Wachstum
Nase durch und ich schlug vor dass wir
etwas zusammenstellen dass die Botschaft
der Marco Polo transportiert
und wir nannten es die Ralph Lauren
Philosophie lausem gab ein markenvideo
in Auftrag das mich inspiriert das ist
eine Geschichte oder ein Thema das mich
anspricht bei mir besteht eine Koalition
nicht aus seinem Ärmel oder einem
bestimmten Stoff sich entwerfe sie aus
einem Traum heraus Kontrolle ist für ihn
sehr wichtig und auf diese Weise konnten
wir eine einheitliche Botschaft
präsentieren er musste nicht dabei sein
aber es war als wäre er dabei gewesen
Lauren expandierte weiter mit Blick auf
den internationalen Absatz eröffnete er
Flagship Stores in Mailand Tokio und
sogar Moskau
Amerika wird in Frankreich von
McDonald's und Ralph Lauren
repräsentiert und ich meine was von
beidem lässt unsere Kultur besser
aussehen ich glaube der Ralph Lawrence
Store ist so eine Art symbolischer
amerikanische Botschaft aber im Sommer
2012 wurde der Designer angegriffen
guten Tag als enthüllt wurde dass die
von Lauren entworfenen olympia-trikots
nicht in den USA hergestellt wurden made
in China das ist China China sie sollten
alle Uniform nehmen und verbrennen das
Unternehmen versprach die Trikots für
die Winterspiele 2014 in den USA zu
produzieren während seiner gesamten
Karriere kultivierte Ralph Lauren sein
eigenes Image sehr sorgfältig er hat
Wohnsitze auf der Fifth Avenue in
Jamaika Long Island und Bedford New York
und eine 17.000 Hektar Ranch in Colorado
wo er Zeit mit seiner Frau und seinen
drei erwachsenen Kindern verbringt und
er gibt viel Zeit und Geld für eine ganz
andere Leidenschaft aus Autos sind Spaß
und Spielzeug und sie bieten dir eine
ganz andere Erfahrung für mich arbeiten
sie sehr hart dieses Werbevideo aus dem
Jahr 2010 kündigte eine Pariser
Ausstellung einiger seiner über 60
Oldtimer an
er hat mir mal gesagt er sammelt vor
allem deshalb Autos weil er sie einfach
liebt und sie zu ihm passen er spielt
keine Kunst im Gegensatz zu den meisten
Menschen in seiner Einkommensklasse er
sagte man kann ein Gemälde nicht fahren
und er liebt es eines seiner Autos zu
nehmen und damit an einem
Sonntagnachmittag herumzufahren
Paul Goldberger sagt das Lauren bei
einigen seiner Autos die Farbe änderte
er sieht sich etwas an und sagt das ist
wunderbar und aufregend und schön aber
es könnte noch schöner sein und ich
möchte es noch perfekter machen
seit 40 Jahren hat Ralph Lauren mit
seinem Streben nach Perfektion das
Unternehmen das seinen Namen trägt als
CEO und Vorstandsvorsitzender fest im
Griff
ich glaube das Symbol mit dem Polo Pony
hat Bestand es ist etwas das die Kunden
über einen langen Zeitraum gewählt haben
das ist wahrscheinlich die beste
Geschichte in meiner Berichterstattung
weil es so viele Wachstumsmöglichkeiten
gibt mit denen sich der Umsatz in den
nächsten Jahren wohl mehr als verdoppeln
wird
[Musik]
der ehemalige krawattenverkäufer ist mit
72 Jahren einer der reichsten Menschen
der Welt und siebeneinhalb Milliarden
Dollar schwer ich glaube dass das letzte
Stückchen Ralph Lipschitz das in ihm
geblieben ist ein Kern von Unsicherheit
ist und das ist der Treibstoff der den
Motor antreibt der die Person antreibt
die diese Marke verkörpert
Ralf ruht sich nicht eine Minute lang
auf seinen Lorbeeren aus ich meine man
kann den Moment genießen aber man muss
verstehen dass man die Dinge am Laufen
halten muss man darf kein one tree Pony
sein apropos
in der rüdes sevre 40 im Herzen von
Paris befindet sich der Hauptsitz von
kehring dem Luxus Giganten zudem neben
Goji als Hauptmarke auch
yvesa und Balenciaga gehören ein
Meisterwerk von 1600 mit Garten einem
17.000 Quadratmeter großen Gebäude und
einer Kirche im Inneren der Gucci Happ
befindet sich in der Via mit schenade 79
in Mailand
35.000 Quadratmeter in einer ehemaligen
restaurierten Flugzeugfabrik es umfasst
einen sechsstöckigen Turm für Büros und
Designer einen Showroom einen Raum für
Modeschauen und auch einen lindenwald
aber in der Via industria 19 in
kadempino in diesem anonymen Gebäude
zwischen der Autobahn und dem
Tennisplatz werden 80% der Gewinne der
gesamten kehring-gruppe erzählt ein
nettoge von 1,7 Milliarden Franken im
Jahr 2017
[Musik]
[Applaus]
nachdem Gucci 20 Jahre lang über die lgi
in kadempino Steuern im Tessin gezahlt
hat hat das Unternehmen das zur
kehring-gruppe gehört das Finanzamt in
den Ländern zurückerobert in denen die
Arbeiter den Reichtum produzieren dieses
Jahr verlässt der größte Steuerzahler
den
kantona
hat dies bestätigt ihr machte das was
alle Gucci nennen jährlich 3/4 der
Steuereinnahmen aus
[Musik]
was genau hat ihnen lgi im Dezember wenn
ich mich nicht irre gesagt
es war noch November sie teilten uns mit
dass wir aufgrund einer Änderung in
Ihrem Unternehmen in den nächsten Jahren
weniger Steuern erhalten
genau wie viel weniger
im Jahr 2019
80% weniger als ihr üblicher Standard
und ab 2020 dann 95% weniger
5% der Einnahmen die bisher von lgi
bezahlt wurden
Konzern wird in der Schweiz deutlich
weniger Steuern zahlen und hat bereits
angekündigt vorerst 150 Mitarbeiter zu
versetzen kadepino wird jedes Jahr 8
Millionen Franken verlieren der Kanton
sogar mehr als 20
hier ist der Platz mit den Steinen
Granit oder was weiß ich und drumherum
wird die Bepflanzung sein einschließlich
etwaiger Dekoration des Platzes Pflanzen
und andere Dinge
mit 1.500 Einwohnern bis heute die
reichste Stadt des Tessins ist das
Symbol für die enormen Einnahmen die der
luxusriese jährlich garantiert mit
diesem Geld werden das neue Gemeindehaus
und der Platz fertiggestellt eine
Investition von rund 10 Millionen
Franken
[Musik]
es ist wirklich groß war es eine
ungewöhnliche Investition für eine Stadt
mit 1500 Einwohnern so los Bazi das sind
große Räume die Platz für Entwicklung
bieten also
fürchten sie den Wegfall der Einnahmen
aus ihren wirtschaftlichen Ressourcen
verändert
früher waren wir Onkel Dagobert es war
nur so weil wir Glück hatten und wir
Administrator wir haben die mittelgut
verwaltet und können sicherlich die
nächsten fünf Jahre ohne Probleme
weitermachen
in diesen Jahren hat cadempino 30
Millionen Franken beiseite gelegt die
ist der Gemeinde nun ermöglichen das
Schlimmste zu verhindern
[Musik]
eine kalte Dusche nicht nur für die
Gemeinde sondern auch für den Kanton und
folglich auch auf Bundesebene und ich
denke wir haben kein Recht uns aus
irgendeinem Grund zu beschweren
Umsatzrückgang bei lgi worauf ist der
zurückzuführen
auf die Umstrukturierung die Sie
innerhalb des Unternehmens hatten das
ist die Veränderung die Beziehungen die
wir hatten sind gut
wir sollten hier diskretionen denn das
Unternehmen selbst hat auch immer
Diskretion waren lassen
heute wird jedoch gegen den Konzern von
der Staatsanwaltschaft Mailand ermittelt
wonach er gerade über die Tessiner
Niederlassung lgi luxury kurz
international se zwischen 2011 und 2017
Steuern in Höhe von 1,4 Milliarden Euro
hinterzogen und Einnahmen in Höhe von
14,5 Milliarden Euro nicht deklariert
haben soll
oder die Tatsache dass gingen sie wegen
Steuerhinterziehung ermittelt wird von
dem Unternehmen bei ihrem Treffen
erwähnt
nein wir wir haben nicht über
Untersuchungen gesprochen auch weil es
nicht an uns liegt zu wissen oder nicht
zu wissen warum gegen sie ermittelt wird
wenn gegen sie ermittelt wird
aber wir haben von den Zinsen profitiert
die sie uns gegeben haben und das ist
genug für uns ich persönlich habe nicht
zu beanstanden
es tut mir leid dass dieses Geld
woanders hingeht aber solange sie hier
waren hat sich niemand beschwert denn es
gab nur einen Verlust zu verzeichnen
auf kantonaler Ebene bei den Steuern
haben Sie sich jemals gefragt wie ein
Unternehmen wie lgi so viele Gewinne in
cadempino erzählen konnte akadembino
wir haben uns nie darum gekümmert wie
sie diese Gewinne erzielt haben
der lgi-hauptsitz in kadempino
erwirtschaftete 2017 einen Reingewinn
von fast 1,7 Milliarden Franken zum
Vergleich das ist ein höherer Gewinn als
bei Swisscom und doppelt so hoch wie bei
Swatch wie wir bereits in einem Bericht
von vor zwei Jahren aufzeigten hat lgi
mit nur 800 Angestellten im Vergleich zu
den 30.000 Angestellten im Rest der Welt
seit Jahren den größten Teil der
Gewinner des multinationalen
luxuskonzerns kehring in der Schweiz
konzentriert wo er eine privilegierte
kantonale Besteuerung von 8% genießt ein
äußerst wettbewerbsfähiger Satz im
Vergleich zu den Steuern im Rest der
Welt
was war die Funktion der lgi die diese
stratosphärischen gewinnerechtfertigte
eine Quelle die der Spitze des
Unternehmens sehr nahe steht hat mit uns
gesprochen wir durften weder sein
Gesicht Filmen noch Details über ihn
preisgeben wir konnten lediglich unsere
Gespräche aufzeichnen und nun davon
berichten Hering erklärt dass die
Tessiner Niederlassung kommerzielle
Tätigkeiten ausübte aber was geschah
wirklich in der lgi
es gab große Büros in denen den ganzen
Tag über Rechnungen gedruckt wurden mehr
nicht in der Schweiz wurden logistische
und buchhalterische Aufgaben
wahrgenommen
auf keinen Fall es gibt überhaupt keine
es gibt nichts kein Käufer ist jemals in
cadantino gewesen
haben sie gerade Pino gesehen glauben
sie kann im Pino repräsentiert die Marke
ich meine es ist ein Lagerhaus ein
Hangar der Verkauf von Gucci findet in
Mailand statt Laven die da die
gucciate aber dass lgi eine kommerzielle
Plattform sei
ze ich habe nie gesehen dass bei lgi
gehandelt wurde es gab eine
institutionalisierte Falschdarstellung
dessen was lgi für Steuerzwecke Tat eine
Art betrug
warum verlässt die hering-gruppe das
Tessin wir haben sie ihren Weggang
begründet
zu bleiben waren die Steuern und nur die
Steuern mit dem Wegfall der
Steuervergünstigungen seitdem die
italienische Staatsanwaltschaft gegen
sie wegen Steuerhinterziehung ermittelt
ergibt der Verbleib im Tessin keinen
Sinn mehr denn der würde nur
betriebliche Ineffizienz und einen
Anstieg der Kosten bedeuten
ihre Mitarbeiter bereits über die
Verlagerung nach Italien insbesondere
nach Novara informiert ein
Logistikzentrum und ein Werk besitzt das
bereits erweitert wird über seine
eigenen Entscheidungen bewahrt das
Unternehmen äußerste Diskretion aber es
ist uns gelungen mit einigen
Mitarbeitern zu sprechen auch in diesem
Fall wird niemand zu erkennen sein
das einzige was Sie von einem wollen ist
wir mussten eine
Geheimhaltungsverpflichtung
unterschreiben sie wollen nicht dass
jemand darüber spricht es geht das
Gerücht um dass sie bald mit allem
umziehen werden bei lgi sind die
Gehälter im Vergleich zu den
schweizerischen Standards viel niedriger
sie liegen zwischen 3.400 und 3.800
Franken pro Monat wenn man bereits etwas
Erfahrung hat für die Versetzung nach
Italien wurde dasselbe Gehalt
vorgeschlagen allerdings mit
italienischer Besteuerung das heißt 40%
weniger
für diejenigen die bereits in Italien
leben also fast alle in der Firma ist
das in Ordnung aber die wenigen
Schweizer die dort arbeiten wurden in
die Knie gezwungen
dort irgendwelche kommerziellen
Aktivitäten durchgeführt oder wichtige
Entscheidungen getroffen nein
das war eine rein logistische und
buchhalterische Angelegenheit der Rest
ist in kallepin nur sicher nie passiert
wir wussten irgendwie dass es für lgi
ein etwas fadenscheinigen Grund gab in
der Schweiz zu sein
zum Beispiel werden in cadempino
Etiketten gedruckt und an die
Lieferanten geschickt man hat uns immer
gesagt dass wir das tun müssen um zu
zeigen dass wir dort an der Produktion
beteiligt sind
meinen sie die Etiketten die in die
Kleidung eingenäht sind genau aber sie
sagten sie müssten in der Schweiz
gemacht werden und das war's haben die
Arbeiter gemacht nein nein früher haben
wir das gemacht sie die Büroangestellten
ja wir haben uns abgewechselt um uns um
diese Dinge zu kümmern
aber die Steuern werden dort bezahlt wo
die Hauptaktivitäten stattfinden wie
konnten sie rechtfertigen dass eine
reine logistik-niederlassung in
kadempino Gewinne in Höhe von 1,7
Milliarden Franken erwirtschaftet diese
Frage scheint bei Gucci im Mittelpunkt
der Überlegungen gestanden zu haben denn
je größer sie wurde desto mehr musste
sie rechtfertigen das wertschöpfende
Tätigkeiten in der Tessiner
Niederlassung durchgeführt wurden wo sie
Steuern zahlte die Lösung eine Liste von
22 Managern die offenbar im Tessin
Arbeiten und Wohnen
es gab Direktoren die sich als unsere
manager-ausgaben obwohl sie es in
Wirklichkeit nicht waren sie schienen
ein Büro in cadem Kino zu haben aber wir
haben sie nie gesehen die wichtigen
Männer waren sicherlich nicht in
calimpino tatsächlich wurden ihre Büros
als Besprechungsräume genutzt weil jeder
wusste dass sie nie da waren verdammt
okay
sie hatten einen gefälschten Wohnsitz um
einen Beweis dafür zu liefern das
wichtige Führungsaufgaben in der Schweiz
wahrgenommen wurden gleichzeitig stellte
die Gruppe diesen Managern
bürosekretariat der organisatorische und
operative Unterstützung in Italien zur
Verfügung
in Italien
sehr selten fast nie
haben Sie jemals wirklich in diesen
Wohnungen gelebt
sie haben nie dort gewohnt die
Wohnungsverwaltung wurde den
Angestellten überlassen einige
Assistenten wurden geschickt um von Zeit
zu Zeit die Post abzuholen und die
Stromzähler zu kontrollieren indem sie
ab und zu das Licht einschalteten und
die Waschmaschinen laufen ließen damit
der Stromverbrauch glaubwürdiger war
Elektriker
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wie Sie aus dieser internen E-Mail
ersehen können hat keiring selbst die
Versetzungen in die Schweiz vorbereitet
und zwar nicht für irgendwelche stellen
sondern für Schlüsselpositionen im
Unternehmen zum Beispiel Robert trifus
Leiter des Marketings Diana zanetto
Leiterin des Merchandising Fabio duso
stellvertretender Leiter des
Einzelhandels und mehr Leiter der
Personalabteilung Leiter der
Schuhabteilung die Liste ist lang nach
unseren Informationen hat praktisch
keiner von ihnen jemals einen Fuß ins
Tessin gesetzt für zwei Personen ist
jedoch eine Sonderbehandlung reserviert
die beiden höchsten Gucci
schwitzenpositionen Patricio di Marco
und Marco bizari
zu unserer Rettung haben wir einige sehr
interessante und exklusive Dokumente
erhalten es handelt sich um dieselben
Dokumente die mediapat erhalten und mit
einem Konsortium von
enthüllungstournalisten geteilt hat
Patricio di Marco der bis 2014 im Amt
war war offenbar in der Schweiz ansässig
wo er eine pauschalsteuerregelung genoss
mit dem Mietvertrag in der Hand sehen
wir uns an wo der gucci-präsident wohnte
[Musik]
wissen Sie ob Patricia gewohnt hat
ich kenne ihn nicht der CEO von Gucci
haben sie ihn jemals hier gesehen die
Marco nein darf ich Ihnen ein Bild
zeigen damit Sie mir sagen können ob sie
ihnen jemals gesehen haben ja wie lange
leben sie schon hier vier Jahre vier
Jahre okay ja diese Person kennen Sie
sie haben sie ihn jemals gesehen
tut mir leid ich kenne ihn nicht
leben sie schon lange hier ja mindestens
vier oder fünf Jahre
wenn ich Ihnen ein Bild zeige haben sie
ihn vielleicht schon mal hier gesehen
auf keinen Fall sie haben ihn nie
gesehen
[Musik]
Faktor in die sie kommen kostet die
Wohnung neben meiner ist leer seit ich
hier bin es steht also schon seit vier
Jahren leer auf jeden Fall ja
die Marco wurde hier nie gesehen allein
die Prämie für Kleidung die die Marco
von der Firma erhielt war höher als die
Jahresmiete dieser Wohnung kann man
wirklich glauben dass der Präsident von
Gucci mit seinem Jahresumsatz von
mehreren Millionen eine 3.600 Franken
Wohnung im ersten Stock mit Blick auf
die Bahn angemietet hatte
[Musik]
1.500 Quadratmeter 44 Zimmer 5 Etagen
die sich über drei Hausnummern
erstrecken mit der Adresse in der Hand
erreichen wir eine andere Art von
Aussicht auf die die Fenster von DeMarco
blicken
[Musik]
wer ist da guten Morgen Ich wollte
fragen ob es möglich ist mit Herrn
Patricio di Marco zu sprechen
wer fragt ich bin Anna Bernasconi wir
arbeiten für das Schweizer Fernsehen
ja nein denn er ist nicht da
er ist nicht zu Hause nein er ist nicht
zu Hause die Marco scheint mit seiner
Tochter und seiner Frau in dieser Villa
auf dem gianigolo in einem der
angesehensten Viertel Roms zu wohnen
Frieda janini die berühmte ehemalige
Designerin von Gucci stand tatsächlich
am Fenster
ich habe mich gefragt ob es möglich ist
mit Herrn die Marco zu sprechen er ist
nicht zu Hause er ist nicht zu Hause ich
wollte ihnen um einige Informationen
bitten über laufende Ermittlungen
ich weiß davon nichts ich werde mit
meinem Mann darüber sprechen
ich wollte etwas über seinen Wohnsitz in
der Schweiz erfahren nein er ist in
Italien ansässig
gegenwärtig aber früher war er in der
Schweiz ansässig hören Sie ich rufe Sie
zurück
das ist die Information die ich haben
wollte
okay danke
[Musik]
dasselbe gilt auch für Marco bizarri den
derzeitigen Vorsitzenden der Gruppe
Pauschalpreis Wohnsitz in wiko Morcote
wohin er jedoch nie einen fußgesetz zu
haben scheint
[Musik]
ist das nicht der Typ der ganz oben
wohnt den schon mal jemand gesucht hat
sicherlich haben schon andere
Journalisten nach ihm gesucht es ist
schon jemand aus Italien gekommen um ihn
zu suchen aber ich habe ihn nie gesehen
was wäre wenn ich Ihnen ein Bild zeigen
würde warten sie kurz ich komme
ich habe nie gesehen ich sehe ihn da
jetzt auf dem Foto aber nein ich kann
Ihnen nicht helfen wie lange leben sie
schon in diesem Haus 38 Jahre 38 Jahre
genau hier ich hätte ihn sehen müssen
zumindest im Auto genau aber dass der
CEO von Gucci genau hier gewohnt haben
soll
nein das haben sie auch nicht gewusst
ich habe nie gesehen nein
sowohl gegen bizzari als auch gegen die
Marco wird von der Staatsanwaltschaft
Mailand ermittelt bizzari arbeitet und
lebt in Mailand und zwar seit Jahren im
Dachgeschoss eines der exklusivsten
Gebäude hinter der piazadora ich werde
Ihnen ein Bild zeigen
kennen sie ihn kommt er hierher um
Kaffee zu trinken da kann man ein paar
mal vorbei ja
er wohnt hier
[Musik]
ich habe bizari nie im lgi gesehen
zumindest soweit ich weiß pizzari sagen
wir mal er ist leicht zu erkennen sie
haben ihn noch nie gesehen nein ich habe
ihn nie gesehen und ich habe noch nie
Kollegen sagen hören dass sie bizarre
gesehen haben
Patricio di Marco nein auch nicht
die Marke
haben den Steuervorteil genutzt und sind
nie nach keinem Pino gekommen nun das
Management das sind die Funktionen mit
Mehrwert sie sollten in der Schweiz
bleiben und ihre Aufgaben dort erfüllen
so dass die Marge in der Schweiz korrekt
zugewiesen wurde
welche Überprüfungen wurden durchgeführt
als Mann den beiden supermanagern die
Marco und bizari das globalistische
Regime gewährte hat man nie eine
Unregelmäßigkeit in Bezug auf die
Herkunft ihrer Einkünfte bemerkt die
beitragsabteilung lehnte ein Interview
diesbezüglich ab und berief sich in
einer schriftlichen Erklärung auf das
Steuergeheimnis
soviel ich weiß haben die Behörden das
nie überprüft ja die Wahrheit ist dass
das einfach niemand kontrolliert hat
[Musik]
und wie wurde die Marke bezahlt es gibt
neue vertrauliche Dokumente die
ehemalige Nummer eins von Gucci erhielt
demnach zusätzlich zu ihrem regulären
Gehalt in Italien eine zweite Vergütung
als Berater diese Vergütung wurde im
ersten Jahr von der lgi in cadempino
gezahlt bis die Marco im Jahr 2010 die
Globalisierung in der Schweiz beantragte
allerdings darf man kein Schweizer
Einkommen haben wenn man diese
Steuervorteile erhalten will wie konnte
das Problem gelöst werden ganz einfach
durch die Übertragung des
Beratervertrags von der Tessiner lgi auf
eine gewisse Castella ein Unternehmen
mit Sitz in Luxemburg eine inoffizielle
Vergütung die über eine ihrer
Offshore-Gesellschaften in Panama wenn
die international mit einem Konto in
Singapur erzielt wurde es gibt nur
wenige Zweifel daran dass die doppelten
Verträge der reguläre in Italien und
dieser Beratungsvertrag mit dem
luxemburgischen unternehmen castera
nichts weiter waren als ein Spielchen um
einen großen Teil der Vergütung unter
der Hand sein zu können die beiden
Verträge wurden am selben Tag
unterzeichnet die bonusmitteilungen
wurden immer zu denselben Terminen
verschickt und von demselben Präsidenten
von kehring Pino unterzeichnet das wurde
sogar von die Marco zum Zeitpunkt der
Unterbrechung seiner Geschäftsbeziehung
mit der Gruppe bestätigt in der er den
Vertrag mit kastella in Bezug auf
dieselbe und einzige Geschäftsbeziehung
definiert
[Musik]
nur vier Jahren zwischen 2010 und 2014
wurden von castera nach Panama monatlich
Überweisungen in Höhe von insgesamt 24
Millionen Franken getätigt und zwar
steuerfrei in der Schweiz kam die Marco
in den Genuss einer minimalen
Pauschalsteuer von 130.000 Franken das
heißt er zahlte nur 2% Steuern auf sein
tatsächliches Einkommen das ist 20 mal
weniger als er in Italien hätte zahlen
müssen dasselbe gilt für bizari bei
einer jährlichen Nettovergütung von 8
Millionen entgingen 6 Millionen Steuern
durch Luxemburg alles in allem liegt der
Vorteil dieses komplexen verdeckten
Zahlungssystems jedoch bei kehring
selbst das seinen Präsidenten dreimal
weniger zahlen konnte als sie
tatsächlich kosteten z.B für die 24
Millionen die an die Marco in Panama
gingen hätte sie 63 Millionen mit
Steuern zahlen müssen eine beträchtliche
Ersparnis und eine Möglichkeit die
besten Manager einzustellen
wir sind auf dem Weg nach Luxemburg
einer Steueroase im Herzen Europas wo
das Gesetz keine Steuern auf im Ausland
erwirtschaftete Einkünfte vorsieht
la Petrus 124
castera hat die gleiche Adresse wie ein
viel wichtigeres Unternehmen kehring
Luxemburg sa die Muttergesellschaft die
unter anderem den lukrativsten Zweig der
Gruppe kontrolliert die Tessiner lgi
ein Unternehmen mit hunderten von Aktien
und Milliarden von Dividenden hat seinen
Sitz bei dieser Firma die bereits voll
ausgestattete Büros vermietet
ist es möglich mit jemandem von kehring
oder casteder zu sprechen
es ist niemand da
niemand ist hier okay darf ich Sie
fragen wie viele Personen in ihren Büros
arbeiten
ohne ihre Genehmigung kann ich keine
Auskunft geben
wer ist der Direktor des Unternehmens
gibt es einen Leiter für die beiden
Büros
ohne Genehmigung kann ich keine weiteren
Auskünfte erteilen sie können keine
Auskunft geben
sie lassen uns nicht hinein aber nach
dem Grundriss zu urteilen den uns eine
Quelle innerhalb der Gruppe gegeben hat
scheint es sich hierbei ohnehin eher um
eine leere Box zu handeln
[Musik]
sie hatten weder Angestellte noch ein
richtiges Büro es war eine anomale Sache
ein legaler Kasten der Milliarden pumpt
und mehr nicht
wir versuchen die Adresse des einzigen
luxemburgischen Verwalters ausfindig zu
machen der sowohl bei castera als auch
bei kehring Luxemburg auftaucht
[Musik]
aber das ist alles was wir finden
konnten nur ein Briefkasten
sie sind Herr Ackermann
waren Sie persönlich und direkt an der
Unterstützung und Verschleierung der
steuerposition von Herrn die Marko
beteiligt
ich will nicht mit ihnen reden so wie
bei bizzari
[Musik]
Luxemburg stützt sein Steuersystem auf
die tessiner-niederlassung der lgi
Castella dient der diskreten Entlohnung
von Managern die als Globalisten im
Tessin keine Einkünfte in der Schweiz
beziehen können es scheint ein
Gesamtpaket zu sein das kehring
angeboten wird um so viel wie möglich zu
sparen und das mit dem Tessin
verflochten ist
wo wurde eigentlich das Konto der
luxemburgischen Gesellschaft eröffnet
und eingerichtet
die luxemburgische Firma castera
benutzte ein Konto der Credit Suisse in
Lugano das Geld kam von der lgi
Luxemburg war so strukturiert dass es
der Schweiz die Stirn bieten konnte der
steuerfuchs sitzt im Tessin
gehen wir zurück in die Tessiner Sonne
im Folgenden dürfen wir seine Stimme
zwar nicht preisgeben aber wir können
die Dialoge genauso wiedergeben wie sie
stattgefunden haben ein direkter Zeuge
der bisher noch nie gesprochen hat hat
sich bereit erklärt sich mit uns zu
treffen und uns zu verraten wie die
steuerarchitektur des Unternehmens in
der Schweiz aufgebaut und umgesetzt
wurde
wenn man der erste Steuerzahler des
Kantons ist eine bekannte Marke dann
erlaubt einem sein Status Dinge die
andere nicht erlaubt sind wenn man einen
Gast in der Kaiser Suite im Hotel hat
verwöhnt man ihn nicht wahr nun sie
waren Gäste in der Kaiser Suite sie
wurden verwöhnt und man hörte ihnen zu
die Person die die steuerlichen
Positionen der Gucci Manager und die
steuerstruktur des Unternehmens
aufgebaut hat ist ein Treuhänder mit
einem Büro in Lugano vom ersten Tag an
im Verwaltungsrat von Gucci in cadempino
Register
Systems für die Manager war adilio Lady
um die Tatsache zu umgehen dass die
globalistische Pauschalregelung durch
den Nachweis von auslandseinkünften
erreicht wird hat Lady das System in
Luxemburg ausgeheckt damit die Manager
die Marco und pizari jeweils der
globalistischen Regelung nach weniger
Steuern zahlen konnten er war persönlich
an der Erlangung dieser
pauschalsteuerregelung für die beiden
CEO aus beteiligt ja Lady ist das große
Gehirn der Strukturen der Schweiz und
bei all dem war Gucci definitiv der
größte Kunde der Firma
der Treuhänder antwortete uns auch nach
mehrmaligem Nachfragen nicht selbst wenn
wir persönlich in sein Büro gingen wurde
uns gesagt wir sollten unsere Fragen an
das französische Büro von
kehring-stellen
wie kam Gucci ursprünglich nach
cadantino
Gucci River
damals Finanzdirektor der Gucci Gruppe
hatten bei Coopers und librant
zusammengearbeitet und waren durch eine
tiefe Freundschaft verbunden Lady war
Gemeindevertretern cardimpino
Unternehmen der kehring-gruppe rund
250.000 Franken pro Jahr in Rechnung er
war aber auch teilzeitangestellter der
Hering Luxemburg Euro financial
investments Niederlassung mit einem
Festgehalt von 130.000 Franken im Jahr
bei LG i was also praktisch einen
zusätzlichen Mitarbeiter auf der
Lohnliste zu haben noch dazu einen
Schweizer um das Unternehmen glaubwürdig
zu machen um den Anschein einer
Schweizer Mehrheit in den
Verwaltungsräten zu erwecken wurden
weitere in der Schweiz ansässige
Personen eingestellt darunter mehrere
Berater
neben lgi taucht der Name des Tessiner
Treuhänders auch in den Aufsichtsräten
mehrerer Tessiner Modeunternehmen wie
Abercrombie Tom Ford und lorupianer auf
die Firma war auch an der Gesellschaft
beteiligt die Ishikawa besitzt eine
Schuhmarke die von den italienischen
Finanzbehörden wegen Steuerhinterziehung
beschlagnahmt wurde mit einem Eigentümer
der einen scheinwohnsitz im Tessin hatte
und im lgi Verwaltungsrat saß seit der
Ankunft von Gucci im Tessin auch der
Berater Paolo brenni er ist Mitarbeiter
der Anwaltskanzlei masoni und Schwager
von Marina massoni Staatsrätin und
Direktorin des Wirtschafts- und
Finanzministeriums zur Zeit der
Ansiedlung von Gucci im Tessin und heute
Präsident von Ticino Moda die
Führungskräfte von Gucci und die gesamte
Gruppe die im Laufe der Jahre ein und
ausgegangen ist kamen alle bei der Firma
masoni vorbei um ihre Unterschrift zu
leisten alle Urkunden und
Rechtsberatungen wurden dort
durchgeführt
[Musik]
wir haben einen interessanten Austausch
von internen E-Mails erhalten die unter
den Top-Managern von kehring einem der
wichtigsten börsennotierten Unternehmen
in Frankreich verschickt wurden es wird
geschätzt dass sich die über die
Tessiner Niederlassung begangene
Steuerhinterziehung auf 2,5 Milliarden
Euro beläuft der größte Fall von
Steuerbetrug eines Unternehmens in
Frankreich jemals was die Hering
Direktoren in Aufruhr versetzt ist eine
Frage des französischen Senats der 2012
und 2013 zweimal wegen
Steuerhinterziehung ermittelt hat
bezahlt das Unternehmen Mitarbeiter im
Ausland wo sie keine Tätigkeiten ausüben
seien Sie vorsichtig schrieben sie und
versuchten dann in mehreren Anläufen
sich auf eine möglichst unkonkrete
Formel zu einigen um den Senat damit von
ihrer Ehrlichkeit zu überzeugen
tatsächlich hat käring das für die
Bezahlung der Manager eingerichtete
offshore-system verschwiegen und zweimal
falsche Angaben gemacht Verfasser des
Fragebogens ist der Senator der
französischen Republik Eric Bouquet
Leiter der Untersuchungsausschüsse zur
Steuerhinterziehung
[Musik]
würde der Familie Pino hat den Senat
zweimal belogen ich möchte Ihnen einige
Dokumente und E-Mails zeigen die einige
kehring Führungskräfte Palü und du play
geschrieben haben die sich an Sie wenden
auf Ihre Anfrage
seien sie auf der Hut saubere Version
der Antwort auf den senatsfragebogen das
ist unglaublich es ist ernst das
Parlament kann nicht bis zu diesem
Zeitpunkt verachtet werden das ist
absolut inakzeptabel der Senat kann in
dieser Angelegenheit nicht schweigen und
wenn es ein Nachspiel gibt dann muss es
durch die Justiz gehen
steuerhinterziehung ist schwerwiegend
weil sie den Staatshaushalt gefährdet
das Geld wird in Schulen Krankenhäusern
Gemeinden dem was die Gesellschaft
verbessern würde vorenthalten man sagt
uns dass kein Geld da sei und das ist
große Gruppen wie diese gibt die
Frankreich jedes Jahr 80 Milliarden Euro
verlieren ließen
ist das jährliche Defizit unseres Landes
das ist völlig inakzeptabel ist
gefährdet unsere Gesellschaft es mit die
Solidarität auch die Demokratie es sind
nicht die Konzerne die das Steuergesetz
machen es ist das Parlament es ist die
Politik mit einem großen P die über das
Steuerrecht entscheidet diese großen
Konzerne werden morgen die Welt anführen
indem Sie sich dafür entscheiden dort
Steuern zu zahlen wo Sie wollen und
natürlich dort wo es viel billiger ist
das ist definitiv inakzeptabel ein
Unternehmen ist Teil der Gesellschaft es
ist ein Element es ist dazu da
Bedürfnisse zu befriedigen Waren zu
produzieren Dienstleistungen anzubieten
die Gesellschaft voranzubringen es ist
nicht nur eine Maschine die Geld
produziert und Geld verdient es ist auch
eine Verantwortung gegenüber dem Gebiet
und der Gesellschaft
die Menschen können diese Geschichte von
Steuerhinterziehung nicht mehr ertragen
auf Kundgebungen hört man regelmäßig von
steuerparadiessen und
Steuerhinterziehung die Menschen wollen
dass wir dieses Problem wirklich an der
Wurzel packen
drei Fußballfelder groß
330.000 Kubikmeter ohne Logos oder
Schilder
das ist die Erweiterung des Gucci Lagers
in St Antonino was ist die Funktion des
größten Gebäudes im Kanton Tessin jeden
Tag 365 Tage im Jahr kommen 50.000 waren
die bereits für die gesamte Produktion
von Gucci und anderen Marken
fertiggestellt wurden mit Lastwagen in
diesen Lager an werden eingelagert in
Kisten umgepackt und verlassen es wieder
was passiert eigentlich in dieser kurzen
Zeit im Tessin die Rechnungen werden
gedruckt und Luxusprodukte made in Italy
werden vom Tessin aus in die ganze Welt
verkauft
indem man auch auf die
Verrechnungspreise spielt den Verkauf
der Ware die von den Lieferanten zu
einem Preis nahe dem Produktionspreis
kommt und zu einem Preis nahe dem der
Designerläden ausgeht bedeutet das für
Luxusgüter riesige Margen und ermöglicht
so die Realisierung sensationelle
Gewinne im Tessin aber ist die Logistik
eine Funktion die sie rechtfertigt
ihr Job ist im Grunde die Logistik ja
das ist richtig sind die Gehälter gut
nicht so ganz also teils und sind sie
hier ansässig nein in Italien sie sind
Italiener in Italien darf ich Sie fragen
wie groß die Gehaltsspanne ist sie
meinen je nachdem wie viele Stunden wir
leisten sie werden nach Stunden bezahlt
ja bei der Agentur wird noch Stunden
abgerechnet und der Stundensatz liegt
bei so in etwa wir bekommen etwa 17
Franken pro Stunde 17 Franken pro Stunde
ja es ist alles auf Analyse aufgebaut
denn im Grunde handelt es sich um ein
Unternehmen dass sich mit Logistik
befasst während man viele Jahre lang
vorgab es sei ein Unternehmen das alle
seine wichtigsten Funktionen hier
konzentriert hat Logistik ist keine
Hauptfunktion
die Logistik hat warum kommt die
Logistik in die Schweiz
ihre Präsenz in der Schweiz zu
rechtfertigen die Ansiedlung der
Logistik in der Schweiz war notwendig um
die Rolle von lgi zu etablieren und zu
rechtfertigen kehring hat sich bisher
immer für den Warentransport durch die
Schweiz eingesetzt die Logistik in der
Schweiz ist ein extra Schritt aus
steuerlichen Gründen und so ein extra
Schritt ist immer schädliches gehen
Liefertage verloren es gibt eine
Verdopplung der Kosten und das sind
alles kosten die von einem
steuerkreislauf diktiert werden den wir
sehr wohl vermeiden könnten wenn die
Schweiz die aus betrieblicher Sicht
ineffizient ist keinen Steuervorteil
mehr zulässt nun dann ist es sinnlos
warum beschloss die Gruppe ihr eigenes
Lager in St Antonino einzurichten
als die Gruppe beschloss ihr eigenes
Lagerhaus zu bauen suchte sie lange nach
einem Grundstück dieser Größe die Gruppe
wollte sich ursprünglich nicht in Sant
Antonino niederlassen sondern auf einem
Grundstück näher an der italienischen
Grenze es machte keinen Sinn die
Lastwagen in der supraceneriff fahren zu
lassen um eine Fahrt zu unternehmen die
ohnehin nutzlos und teuer war außerdem
handelte es sich um ein problematisches
Grundstück des verbessert werden musste
außerdem war der Multiplikator entsand
Antonino vor der Ankunft von Gucci hoch
wir kommen nicht mit einem so hohen
Multiplikator aber mit unserem Projekt
werden sie ihn senken können weil wir
Ihnen eine Menge Geld geben werden es
gab eine Diskussion mit Vita über die
präventive Senkung des Multiplikators
und der war dem Unternehmen eine große
Hilfe der Multiplikator aus dem Jahr
Jahre vor der Ankunft von Gucci zu
Beginn der Verhandlungen wurde
schrittweise um 15 Punkte gesenkt und
viel auf 65% im Jahr 2014 dem Jahr in
dem das Lager gebaut wurde der
Multiplikator soll nun wieder steigen da
der Konzern die Stadt verlässt und seine
an die Stadtverwaltung gezahlten
Einnahmen um mehr als die Hälfte sinken
Sie diese Änderung der Einnahmen
dass die Gewinne die bisher vollständig
im Tessin besteuert wurden nun aufgrund
einer unternehmenspolitischen Regelung
dort besteuert werden wo das Produkt
hergestellt wird und dort wo es
weiterverarbeitet wird
zu haben
erinnern sie zunächst einmal möchte ich
sagen dass die Bezeichnung Lagerhaus für
diese Anlage die im Wert von mehreren 10
Millionen Schweizer Franken gebaut wurde
etwas zu kurz gegriffen ist die
Lastwagen mit den Waren kommen da
jedenfalls an die waren kommen an und
von dort aus werden sie sortiert
die meisten Menschen die dort arbeiten
sind Lagerarbeiter die Magazine
zum größten Teil ja welche Vorteile
bringt und brachte dieses Unternehmen
dem Gebet
Video im allgemeinen brachte es dem
Gebiet vor allem den Vorteil einen
großen Teil des Industriegebiets und der
wirtschaftlichen Ressourcen neu zu
entwickeln Ressourcen die dann in Form
von Dienstleistungen an die Bevölkerung
weitergegeben werden
und was ist mit den Arbeitsplätzen
wir wissen gibt es 200 Arbeitsplätze von
denen ein kleiner Teil von Einheimischen
besetzt ist
sie eine Ahnung welche Art von Gehältern
im Durchschnitt angeboten werden
ich habe keine Ahnung wie viel sie
angeboten haben
macht ihnen die Vorstellung Angst dass
das Unternehmen eines Tages für immer
weggehen und dieses Gebäude leerstehen
könnte
diese Gruppen können wie wir wissen
gehen sicher reformieren und umziehen
ohne jemanden fragen zu müssen denn es
ist ihre Entscheidung das zu tun
[Musik]
die neue Anlage in dem Lager in rehacino
wurde offiziell von lgi angekündigt aber
ist es wirklich eine Erweiterung oder
ist es nur eine Bestätigung dessen dass
sie sich nur in kleineren Lagern
organisieren um die Logistik komplett
abzubauen
maximale Diskretion von dem Unternehmen
das seit Jahren der größte Steuerzahler
im Kanton ist scheint man nicht einmal
den Namen aussprechen zu können
wir wollten uns lediglich danach
erkundigen ob das Lager hier in der
Hauptsitz ist
ich weiß nichts darüber ich weiß
wirklich nichts
sie haben einen Pullover auf dem
luxusgüterlogistik steht ein guter
Freund von mir hat ihn mir geschenkt
aber sie arbeiten hier ja aber nicht für
das Unternehmen dass sie gerade erwähnt
haben Luxusgüter richtig ja ich arbeite
nicht für Sie wir können dazu nichts
sagen tut mir leid aber für wen arbeiten
sie
ich habe keine Ahnung ich bin nicht von
hier
ich finde es seltsam dass man nicht
sagen kann für wen man arbeitet das
haben sie uns gesagt nichts zu sagen ja
das haben sie uns gesagt
das Unternehmen hat sich nicht zu den
möglichen Änderungen in der Logistik
geäußert sicher ist dass in Tessin
vorerst nur Lastwagen und Kisten
verbleiben ohne den Vorteil von
Steuereinnahmen
[Musik]